I come in today with my mindset
all on doing one thing.
And now it's complete 180, we're doing something else.
Not only! Are we doing something completely different, we have to do it in a really really short amount of time.
We need it to be cool.
We need it to be special.
Jake pitched Audible on this shadow idea.
Which, I don't think he really had an idea. (laugh)
So, we're shooting on Wednesday, which is two days from now.
And like a day or two for shooting.
A day or two of editing.
And then, a week of effects. And we chose an effects heavy video.
Would you be shooting this?
No, because I have three videos to make this week.
Okay, so who would shoot it?
Hey Niko
What's up
What's a set piece?
Set piece is a moment of coolness, a little self-contained spectacle bit that
makes you go "Ooh." Basically it's an after effects project file.
Fifty-two times twelve. Last year I blocked almost two thousand phone numbers from my phone
I get about five... six phone calls a day from telemarketers
Every time they call, I don't answer and then I block the phone number instantly
The next day I get another four to five phone calls from telemarketers
from a whole new set of phone numbers and then I have to do it again
And then the next day and the next...
The only day they do not call is Sunday.
Always after 9 and before 10 PM
It's really annoying because I have a FitBit
and my arm will just vibrate every time telemarketers call.
This has been going on since last January, so 2016.
I may have a solution to permanently get all the telemarketers to stop calling me
We have a brand integration for Audible
You guys have seen a couple Audible integrations in the Sam and Niko channel
which Wren has graciously recommended some great books to you guys.
Wren: I LOVE BOOKS!
I love books... They're great
But this time they've actually agreed to do an integration on the Corridor channel
The downside is we have to turn around a video idea really quickly now
'Cause they want the integration to come out by April 30th
So we've got to write an idea and get it made and get it out there before the deadline hits
otherwise we lose the integration.
Except you guys are gonna be at NAB
Or at flight fest
So we have to make a video before NAB?
Jake pitched Audible on this shadow idea
which I don't think he really had an idea...
I think he was just like "Shadows. What if?"
This is a spiritual successor to brush with death, to paper cuts
It's like there's a very cool, just like perspective theme to it, right?
The idea of projections.
We spent like two weeks last year working on some shadow video just like this
and it went nowhere.
so we're revisiting it again this year.
Yeah... We need an outline by the end of the day
I would say it would be up to you to direct the piece
in terms of like everything leading up to when shadows start to play.
Really just focusing on the mood, the setups, the pay offs
And then I'd let Wren handle the visuals
So I'm that we do something way scarier
There's two guys. Like they're breaking into a property.
They kind of split up. 'Cause like this one guy sees that there's this light on this...
Creature that's also a shadow leans out of the darkness and encroaches on him.
This shadow creature if it grabs this guy it affects him in real life
So like maybe it reaches out and grabs a backpack
And so you can realize if this shadow creature touches your shadow, it affects you for real
[Pantomimes creature] Like the shadow just... to that guy's shadow. And then real life
Like stabs him through just "Gyaaah"
Yeah then real life, like you see the guy like blackness appears in his chest...
And like sucks into him
Actually yeah, so what if it starts as black but then slowly becomes transparent
But because the back is also kinda dark and black it doesn't feel transparent right away
until he's completely gone. You realize you're just staring at nothing.
Yeah
Now we've set the stakes. We know that if you get hit by the shadow creature
you get turned into a shadow.
...so now, his friend comes into the room.
I'm going to register my cell phone on the Do Not Call Registry from the FTC
It's the grumpy people list. Go to donotcall.gov
Do Not Call Registry does not expire. But what I was Googling it said it takes
about thirty one days to enact.
Even if I do this, I still have to block 162 phone calls by the end of this month.
Dude... You loving those chips?
Dude where'd those chips come from, son?
Chip fairy.
The chip fairy?
You literally can't stop once you eat one.
Dude these look really hot, like spicy hot.
You are covered in sweat!
It's real dude!
Gotta keep eating them man or else you just shut down.
Like once you start eating these things, you just hav-- you can't stop.
'Cause your body will just shut down and like... you start sweating... It's like... Oof...
Don't judge me!
Oh no!
Maybe he grabs like a two by four and like sets it up, projects on the wall
so the thing can't get through the wall.
The light switch on the other side of the room
"It's always called the thing that the characters on the screen worry about
but the audience don't care."
And all the light are on the ceiling
He ascertains that he can turn on that light switch he'll turn on all the lights in the room
thereby destroying the shadows
So he needs to get to that light switch.
Trips on the cord!
...That has this one light that's still on
and the whole room falls into darkness.
And he's like "Oh shit"
Now he's completely surrounded by shadow and like you film like
a dude on a black background.
You should like reach and like, it should be like--
Like he's trying to get closer but it's like getting closer and closer
You can actually see like the black hands like go on his face?
The darkest hour of the character?
Yeah, the darkest hour. Exactly.
I do like this idea.
It sets up the stakes at the beginning.
Cool visuals that probably won't actually be that hard to do
If we do it well.
It's got a darkest hour where things get the worst they can possibly be
and they get solved right afterwards.
...much bigger problem at the end.
Who do you have play the dude?
Brett and I. Brett and I.
Have Christian call Brett Skate, then.
He gives us this week to shoot it and edit it
and next week to do effects, sound and music.
So is there like some film rights?
You should listen to the 80s synth from Film Riot.
Dark electronic suspense.
Well, I don't get as many calls as Carmichael does but
if I don't know the number I just let it go.
I hate that.
Since I'm a freelancer in production, it could be someone calling
asking me to gaff or crew or whatever
So hopefully I just trust that they're going to leave a message
and I can immediately call them back and still get the job
versus missed the call, not get the thing, and then not get the job because they called someone else.
Registering right now?
Yeah
And I got computer problems but whatever.
We've come up with an overarching idea
just gotta actually write it.
Tricky part here is now we have to come up with the specifics
We need to lay out exactly what happens.
Yeah, I tweeted this a few days ago
but it's like literally the hardest thing I find to do here at work is
literally just coming up with ideas.
Which is strange, I always thought you were a big ideas guy.
I mean, I mean, yeah. But like... sure.
But that is-- I consider coming up with a good idea worth doing is way more difficult
than any other visual effects, the production side. Those are all technically hard
this is very implicitly hard.
You know there's like-- there's no way-- there's no tangible way to measure a good idea
until it's like done and uploaded.
You know you can have an overall concept that's cool but then you'll be like
What's my idea for this line of dialogue?
What's my idea for how I step into this scene?
How much tension do I want for this moment?
Yeah you've just gotta fall back to how you know how to structure a scene
You know our goal here is to get a cool script completely done today
It'll probably get revised a little bit tomorrow
and it'll probably get revised a little bit while shooting
But the biggest problem I see is that it has to get turned around so fast
And I won't be here, that's gonna be really on you and Jake
to have the mood and the flow figured out in your minds.
And you have to turn it around super fast
You have to make sure that it's efficiently shot and efficiently edited
and that all the beats are really covered.
I hope that goes smoothly.
Hopefully we don't miss this integration opportunity.
That's budget that actually covers the next videos we make for the next month so... yeah...
I have to think through the haze of lack of food.
The next step in our pre-production day is to just continue
We've only done eleven shots so far?
We'll get lunch, get back, and finish the day doing these previous stuff
and hopefully we'll be prepared for tomorrow.